[Musique]
J'ai dit que ces emplois avaient quitté l'
Ohio, ils revenaient tous,
il n'aurait pas dû mettre la vie de sa famille en
jeu
pour qu'il soit devant la caméra,
j'ai un gars milliardaire millionnaire qui
travaille pour moi, il fait un sacré boulot
travail
musamba youngstown à
bord de fabio nu
président trump président trump voit
qu'il est un homme d'affaires il voit ça
et il fait ce qu'il doit faire ce qui
doit être fait pour ramener les emplois
et je dis hé tu sais ce que je crois
en ce gars je crois  ce qu'il dit, le
chômage dans le secteur manufacturier était au plus bas, il y
avait plus d'emplois que nous n'avions jamais eu, nous ne pouvions pas
embaucher des gens ici, donc il
s'appelle gino de fabio, c'est youngstown
[Applaudissements]
donc je suis resté ici avec les enfants
et puis  il a
décidé de nous quitter pour que nous puissions
garder notre
vie comme elle est en ce qui concerne les finances euh
probablement la décision la plus difficile que nous ayons jamais
prise ensemble
nous avons tous les deux pleuré j'ai des amis dans la région
qui vivent la même chose
je veux dire je  'je suis juste moi'  Je suis bouleversé à ce sujet pour être
honnête à propos de toute la situation,
ma famille est coincée dans l'Ohio maintenant,
nous avons donc perdu beaucoup d'emplois, comme
c'était le cas il y a 30 à 35 ans,
si vous n'aimiez pas un emploi, vous pouviez
quitter là-bas et partir.  à côté
commence le lendemain ces jours sont révolus
dc
[Applaudissements]
mais le président trump ne va nulle part
pas pendant quatre ans
pour mary catherine bucherin républicain
donald trump nona parfait
il y avait des ficelles qu'il aurait pu tirer
et j'ai l'impression qu'il était juste
devant  la caméra ici mais je suis parti
maintenant tellement désolé je n'ai pas pu t'aider tu es
tout seul
tous tes pouvoirs tournent le travail
démocrates
je ne suis content ni de l'un ni de l'autre mais les
choix que nous avons c'est en quelque sorte un
moindre deux maux
j'ai vraiment envie d'aller regarder
les débats et de voir que
vous savez quel genre de peluches en ressort,
nous sommes en fait allés à
yamato
flexible, nous devons faire
réélire le président Trump pour quatre ans de plus
[Musique]
présidence électorale
pour meurtre